I just want to introduce myself really
briefly my name is Sasha thury I'm the
district director for e-learning
Technologies at kyoga Community College
and um I'm going to talk a little bit
about a project we did in um pre-algebra
which was a an actually a gamified moo
and um part of the reason I chose Eminem
for our our first slide here is because
um I love what we're doing overall in
the field and then I get to take all of
this amazing stuff and bring it back to
the Community College environment and
try to bring it back to kind of the
ground floor and the people that I serve
and U my personal mission and we're
going to get there um kind of at the in
the discussion part is what is your
mission in terms of the audience you're
serving and what are you hoping to
accomplish um so so this is me if you
want to um I didn't realize there was a
hashtag for the conference overall so if
you want to hashtag the conference
that's fine too I'm Sasha T bear at just
about everything thing or you can go to
my site which is edus sasa.com I'm a big
big believer in collaboration so if
anybody wants to get together after this
and make something happen um let me know
okay so have you all seen this graphic
which I love which is creative comm's
license of course um so there was a big
controversy right like what are mukes
are they going to take away every
Everything known as traditional
education um and and if you're like me
if you're from The Princess Bride
generation this probably means quite a
bit to you I don't necessarily think
that they mean what you think that they
mean and then we just saw this this
graphic right we're all I'm sure
familiar with this graphic um but when
we talk about mukes the majority of
mukes are not the demographic that I
serve and in fact they're not the
demographic that we were able to hit
with our Muk and it's kind of a
different animal when you're trying to
reach out to an audience that is not
part of the connected Community um so
this was our Muk so I'm actually going
to stand up here because it's it's a
little bit well no you can probably see
that okay so I renamed everything right
so in addition to um M being for massive
it's also for um the fact that we used
it for Math deved and I'm talking deved
pre-algebra really kind of basic content
and just to give you a sense of our
institution and why they were involved
in this initiative is we have a huge
deved challenge specifically in math
also in English but far more extreme
nature in math and what we're trying to
do is get these students into college
level math the students who would have
placed say into this course would have
had three semesters of math classes
ahead of them to get to college level
math so that's um that's a pretty
significant Challenge and what we're
trying to do is not make that take away
their federal financial aid so they
don't have to pay for this um not make
it take an entire semester which they
lose of the ability to take a different
class in that time time and um there's a
Time clock on all this the faster they
get through deved the more likely they
they are to be um successful in getting
an associates degree or a Workforce
certificate um it's also massive because
it's actually a fiscally sustainable
model uh our state funding is going to
more of a success-based model as opposed
to an entrance based model so previously
we got a lot of funding from serving and
underserved population that funding is
being radically transformed our
enrollment funding is gone so it's all
based on course completion certain
things called success points and then
exit so it's really important for us to
find a way to scale Dev Ed um and then
because it's massive it it also assists
with our mission of access so now we're
focused on success but we didn't change
our mission anybody can come to a
community college that's why I'm at a
community college um I I mean I have a
degree but that's why I work at a
community college um and then the open
part of it is we used all open
educational re uh resources so we didn't
create anything out of whole cloth with
the exception of some of the videos we
used um didn't have closed captioning
and because we model what it is that
we're hoping our faculty do we had those
Clos captioned um we also used a free
textbook that we got from connections um
and then the the online part is kind of
interesting um our students don't always
have a real concrete sense of agency so
a connection between the work that doing
and the results that come out of it
sometimes these things feel like they're
out of control that maybe they have more
to do with luck than with purpose so
what we did was we used a gamified
environment and that creates what we
what we call a lowrisk failure so a
student could come and jump right to the
first level assessment and then fail it
and then they could go back and review
resources and try it again and fail it
again and go back and try it again and
fail it again we don't care as long as
they have eventually get to 80% success
which was our criteria we didn't do c
and above because our data shows that if
a student gets a c in a deved class sure
they'll pass that course they're not
going to pass the next one so they're
not going to be successful in their next
class so that's why we set the bar a
little bit higher um we also it's my
personal Fascination this concept of
building resilience and gamified
environments tend to do that in addition
to the sense of agency but they also um
they also provide like the the
willingness to try again and again which
is what we're hoping they're going to
take away not just from the content but
from the practice of learning that they
will bring back into their um formal
credit based courses so we're we're kind
of trying to model what we want them to
be as a student as well um and then of
course the the C is in our in our case
both for Competency Based education
because it we use game mechanics at was
a competency based course you could not
advance until you achieved 80% on the
level you couldn't even see the next
content until you achieved 80% on the
level so it really um I don't know if
any of you are fans of Jame mcgonagal
that came up in an earlier session but
Gamers fail 80% of the time right so and
um historically our our fail rate in
community colleges for deved maath is
not quite that high but but not too far
away from it nationally so it's really
important that we um provide
environments where our students are not
going to be um not going to kind of
incorporate into their student
experience the sense that they're
failing but instead give them the sense
that they can just keep trying again and
again and again it was um they they
couldn't get through the success rate in
the course until they made it at 80% so
just a few differences between um the
traditional Muk X xmo caveat um and our
gamified xmo is that um our student
population had little or no College um
many of our students I have some of the
stats there but um they they had some
college and we don't really know what
that entails but it means no degree um
and then we also had a wraparound story
which is interesting we didn't really
get into the narrative concept of games
so um but there is a whole whole another
series of of research and interesting
things about you know taking on the role
of the hero and it goes back to Joseph
Campbell and all that good stuff but
that's not exactly what we did we had
like a loose wrapper round story um we
used existing o are we leveled up we
also used digital badges does anybody
use digital badges uh so we did it for
each level in the moo we used them
within course sites which was the
platform that we used primarily because
our full-time faculty who we had working
on it were used to Blackboard so they
didn't have to learn a new LMS while
they were doing it um but they integrate
with um Milla open badges um so students
can take them with them um we also used
instructional video but it wasn't based
on um an instructor so it wasn't uh a
person that they identified with as
being their instructor at the front of
the classroom in a lecture-based format
so they didn't ever see an embodiment of
an
instructor okay so we also did how am I
doing on my time here okay I got to talk
fast so we had I talk fast normally so
this is probably a little dizzying okay
if have to is is anyone already like
whoa slow down okay is okay okay so we
got this uh Gates Foundation Grant to do
this and we had a pretty ambitious
project that we wanted to do and we had
a a really rapid development cycle we
didn't know it at the time but this
actually made us the First Community
College in the nation to have a moo we
just wanted to get it done so we we came
up with the first iteration of the moo
and then we did it four times and we did
kind of some tweaks along the way
primarily with the facilitation of it
but the idea is that we're able to kind
of make those changes in an agile way um
and this was kind of the gamified story
so we're from Cleveland I'm from
Cleveland and it was you know um like
Survivor I don't watch Survivor but I'm
told this is like a big deal like
Survivor so instead of um Cleveland it
was believe Island there were a lot of
discussions on whether it should be
believeland or believe is
so this is what we came up with and um
we actually got Custom Graphics created
uh actually by the husband of our
instructional designer at the time our
caveat um we work at a community college
so we big borrow and steal resources
from wherever we can um and there's this
kind of wraparound story where you get
through challenges and you're able to
like you know get water or you get your
compass back you're attacked by a band
of monkeys you know but the great thing
about the the course is that you you
don't need the story and in fact the
entire course is openly licensed um if
you go to tri-c.edu Muk you can get to
it you can rip and burn it in its
entirety today you can take it we
encourage you to take it and if you do
take it let us know how it works out
because we want to know um so we had
instructional videos from a variety of
places but as I said they were not
instructor specific there were also
activities that were put in there we had
um checkpoints so before they got to the
level assessment they could kind of self
assess and see how they were doing um
and then they got the badges and they
unlocked the next level so again they
didn't see the level until they were
there um and those are badges it's
interesting because we had someone who
was studying for the GR in our in our
office who took it and has all the
badges now okay so our results really
briefly this was um our level of educ
ational attainment and as you can see
it's very different than what we would
think of as as a typical um moo attendee
or Muk participant um we had a lot of
people that just had some college um 40%
which is an interesting flip from the
average moo right with 40% of them
having master's degrees um and then our
completion stats were actually kind of
uh impressive it ended up being more of
a Luke you know in of a Muk and there
were a couple of reasons for that one is
which is really hard to explain to
people what a Muk is if they're not
really used to online courses even like
um I think over 50% of our people
actually knew what an online cours is
and had taken at least one but a large
segment I think it was like 40% had
never even taken an online course so
this was very different experience for
them and capturing that audience was
really challenging so we were putting
out you know um ads places we were
trying to get all of our students to
take it it was it was definitely
reaching a non- networked audience is a
different animal than reaching a
networked
audience um but oh but when you think
about that that's an amazing success
rate for a moo um
18.4% like I I I've heard between five
and 10% is completion and success right
like five tends to be full success
meaning everything was completed 10%
like it was complete but you didn't do
everything or what so um that's that's
kind of impressive and I attribute it to
the design because if anything we should
have seen less completion rates in aruk
because of our audience we should have
seen less and we saw more so the only
thing it brings me to is back to learner
motivation again learner motivation and
the way it was actually designed um some
of them were currently enrolled so we're
hoping that some of that 27.4% were
actually our students or students we
managed to capture and this is an
interesting comparison um so if you
filter out from our at kyoga Community
College our actual um statistics for
students that passed what would be the
comparable course very similar
objectives um there's only a 10%
differential between our success in
completion rate and the success and
completion rate now granted this is 80%
or above so we didn't include we had
students that passed at Tri C with a c
that aren't in this metric because we
wanted to make it as Apples to Apples as
possible and so um that's kind of
remarkable when you consider um the 18%
didn't have any skin in the game they
didn't have to pay for anything um
nothing was going to happen to them if
they failed the course or failed to
complete the
course ah very good so normal a normal
um time frame would be a 16we semester
you can also take it we also have a 14we
um ours was four
weeks and the reason we made our Muk
only four weeks is because we had looked
at the data now granted totally
different learner demographic but the
data that was coming out at the time and
remember this was two years ago was
showing that in the fourth week Muk
participation was cratering so you were
seeing first week second week third week
fourth week boom and so we were like
okay well let's take the information we
know we have and make it four weeks um I
should also mention that it is currently
open on course sites unfacilitated
anybody can come in and out and the
success rate for that is only
7.44% so I do think the condensed
timeline the fact that it was um focused
in a different way was helpful we also
tend to lose students throughout the
course of the semester at the community
college for various reasons four weeks
is a lot more edible than 14 16 weeks of
material in four weeks though it wasn't
like the first four weeks is the SP same
four weeks it was you took teive they
did take away they didn't take away um
huge chunks of the skill set that was
needed but there wasn't as much um like
as much incremental practice and things
do you know what I mean so it wasn't
like there wasn't as much finals the
same in some sense yes yes and we
tracked it all the way back to the
objectives The Faculty were amazing on
this project we had an amazing team
instructional designers I mean we just
you know it was a $50,000 Grant through
the Gates Foundation but the most
important thing that the Gates
Foundation did was just give us the
legitimacy that they believed in the
potential of this model for us to really
be able to do it not that we wouldn't
this is being videoed not that we
wouldn't love a multi-million dollar
Grant from The Gates Foundation we could
do so much with more than
$50,000 um so we have a little Compass
data here and this is compass are you
guys familiar with compass no okay so
Compass is a placement test that we use
at the community college level it's
actually becoming increasingly
controversial um because so many people
end up placing into devit right like is
this even a good assessment um and we're
not even going to get into the question
of does someone seeking a non- STEM
related associates degree really need to
to graph quadratic equations that's like
a separate question that we're not going
to address here so we only had a a very
limited subset This was
self-reported um and of the 64 students
Who provided us with their s number so
that doesn't mean there were more we
just got the data from these um only 13
took a pre- and post that we could track
it was incredibly messy data to get and
work with and that is what we found was
the ultimate Challenge was getting the
data and filtering it and it was it was
kind of a hot mess but um 76% of them um
placed either in a higher course or
placed out of devet which is weird
because we didn't put content into that
to place them out of Dev so which is
showing us one of two things we use Khan
Academy res resources teacher tube stuff
other stuff so maybe students who were
already going to be successful now were
able to to access the resources to get
them there on their own or they needed a
refresher right so there's a there's a
couple different ways to look at this
and it's 13 like n equals 13 right so
you can't really draw too many
conclusions except it's encouraging
enough to get more data
right okay so this is the reflection
part this is not a pop quiz I just said
that okay so I actually want you to do
this individually right now and then
we're going to I think we can break like
safely maybe into two or three groups um
because I really want uh the the most FR
oh let me touch my microphone the most
frustrating thing I found about the
conference is I'm loving it so much I
want I actually want to talk more about
it and when they're passing around the
microphone sometimes it's like no no I
want that microphone give me that
microphone so what we're going to do is
discuss in small groups and then report
out so you're going to have to come up
with a product um so right now what I
actually want you to do is write down
why you're motivated in mukes so there's
a couple of different reasons I'm doing
this one of which I'm sure you know is
when you define your motivation ahead of
time it's easier for you to decide what
you're going to be doing with it and
also what you want out of this
experience so go ahead and actually
write this down I'm going to actually
time you roughly so start now and I will
come get you at
253 just three
questions
to
for
30 second
warning all right okay so hopefully you
already had a sense of what motivates
you you to to engage in these things but
um the reason I wanted you to write it
down is because some of what we're going
to be talking about is what you've done
with mukes but also what you want to do
with mukes and what as a result of this
or the other presentations you might
want to take a back into your model and
make some changes because uh the whole
theme of this Workshop is we're not
anymore focusing on the scale we are
focusing on the learning so what are
some different ways that we might be
able to do that okay so now we're going
to be in
groups okay um so maybe like the there's
really no good way to do this so maybe
like the three of you here the four of
you my little quadrant back there and
then this half of the room there's only
five of you right you can manage okay so
just take one minute and and introduce
yourself to each other so this is like
force networking right like say your
name what organization you're
from
exchange business cards if you have
them so you R you only have one minute
so don't don't share your life story one
minute
uh go over go over the three questions
the three responses so how are you
guys well weed open courses
year univers so My First was of
ET yeah
that's why they are
interested okay and just to interrupt
for a minute I'm hearing you're already
going this direction so let's go ahead
and go in this direction
um which is when when you're introducing
yourselves or talking about your
projects um go ahead and talk about the
specific purpose of either one you've
created and run or one you've
participated in whatever your preference
is um and what where were you successful
but also how did you define success we
talk a lot about completion rates but
I've been in several mukes I had
absolutely no intention of completing um
so I should I was there to like you know
NAB things or check check it out um and
then who is your audience for either the
Muk you participated in or one you've
designed and did you meet that target
audience so were you either the
demographic that was being targeted for
whatever reason or were you able to find
your targeted audience okay so go ahead
y'all were starting on that anyway so go
ahead
specifically 12
teachers
so have to transfer
concept
EV so I'm trying and say everything I
can I'm
associate Excellence at the University
were to the
ini
ilz
tools
univ
the
um that actually you know we chose to so
the inspector had to know how to build
those because anything you try to do in
higher Lev thinking you can't assess we
waiting to get perspective so for us
it's really important that we get people
to think about diversity inclusion all
over the world not just within
the individuals who sitting anywhere any
place that was really feeling about
becoming a member of catalyst catalyst
so we haven't created a yet um here we
just joined um officially joined a week
ago so it's all about
learning I'm Dan from
College Berkeley online actually which
is our the online part of the
school so for a long time we've been
building 12we courses with 20 students
section
feed
author
instructor more than dipped our toe we
kind of jumped into the put it on
stair to
uh basically you know we've run several
course
strugg
massive so what for you and terms of
success for your course what did you
think what was what was sort of your
metric mitos metrics or it's
really yeah it
was when I first started I wanted to
reach
know and you still had 500 600 people
comping it which is
like you know I mean probably the same
size I really interested
so those people even the people didn't
complete still a lot
of just watching
TR I think they learn a lot more because
they
you have you guys all had a chance to
kind of share or do you need a couple
more minutes
good okay I'm gonna have this bring it
together and
report all right if you could kind of
close up I want to hear a little bit
from each group um there was some great
stuff going on over there and I want to
make sure that everybody can can share a
little bit so why don't I start over
here with our largest
group Inu oh no
really you're still in doing
introduction okay I'll I'll throw
another question at them you
continue I will in one minute thank you
there you guys were
accelerated success in my course for us
it's been so diverse at the
you know
that's
yeah it's a great question Ian something
so
interesting there are like
those complet by the second week and
following those cohorts till the end and
seeing what percentage those are has
been one way I think faculty are sort
looking at it like let's see how many
stay active till the second or third
week for back the second week let's
follow them and see how many of those so
if there were
4,000 or 10,000 completed up to the
second week then they try and follow
those 10,000 to end and out of those
10,000 we've seen sometimes oh% of them
actually did because they were pretty
engaged so that's the
one so is everybody pretty much looking
at completion as the ultimate goal no
okay because I think that's where our
internal conversation started like we
want them to complete the move and it's
been kind of this transforming
conversation because is that the sole
goal of our students is that find out
which students are actually active which
is usually those that are up to second
we and are moving through then you can
look at their assessments and see how
they're actually learn right I want to
ask them too you know what we haven't
ever asked students who come in what
what is your goal in this move we do
that see you post
assment what like answers have you
gotten are they all there to complete or
are they all there to their variety some
are there just to
like just interested looking at it oring
new topics but and then some are there
like yeah I want to learn the whole
course but it's a range
like um how do you define success for us
because we there's also the team
collaboration element on it so when we
like want to assess success you want to
assess it individually or like as a team
some people come in just because they
want to make some connection for example
maybe Tennessee teacher living in a
rural area there's only one of her
teaching you know special culation kids
so she wants to reach out to other
teachers so for her maybe connect with
other teachers that that's sucess
right for example
to how that work question because the
platform and it's like throwings of sand
in the wind
discussion so we can't really analyze
things very well I'm not looking at you
no that's fine should I should I stand s
like right here is better oh my God so I
have a question for you we can ask them
to cut out did you were your is your
open
open it was run originally in four
four-week segments four consecutive four
we segments and that's the one we got
the good success rates when we just
opened it up we pulled the last time we
pulled the data just from cor sites it
was like a
7.4% as opposed to the 18 .4% that we
saw before so we did find I mean it's
probably some combination of it being
specifically marketed as a Muk you know
like this is a four-week nuk as opposed
to this is just living up there you know
but also faculty are are thinking about
using it in different ways now and so it
brings up other conversations like
they're now having conversations about
doing the entire deved math Spectrum
without textbooks right so it takes it
back to a design conversation let's talk
about the content as opposed to the
materials that we're using to deliver
things you know what I mean so it I
think it changes the whole conversation
almost around pedagogy in some ways we
did something really right now the
majority of ours are you can come and go
consume what you want
self-paced um but we took one and we
offered an incentive to
complete we
saw yeah that's true a car
the incentive was um that the mo was one
that a learning portfolio have assessed
for col credit the assessment is
$1,500 and for completing it within 10
weeks we dropped the price to
100 college credit for 100 bikes that's
and you 15 classes inside the portfolio
so it was a monetari you know type
okay encouragement but we saw an
immediate change well I would even
honestly some of our other I would even
I I can't currently because I'm I'm also
a PhD student at Kent State and I can't
currently do a pla or do an E portfolio
to get credit I would still pay for the
credits if I didn't have to sit through
the class do you know what I mean I
would create that new portfolio I'm like
on my last semester of coursework now
and it is it's hard to do with two kids
it's not the content that's killing me
it's the negotiations with my husband
that poor man who was still married
yeah that was I'm glad you brought that
up because that's something we were
thinking about changing you know this
next year some of our structure yeah
it's it's definitely I think just like
when the concept of online courses came
out or the concept of instructional
design it changes the conversation about
what's going on here in the classroom
and I think that that's what we're
seeing I mean it's so interesting we're
all talking about the flipped classroom
now that happened in K12 like 10 years
ago but it's really it's interesting
that yeah we're all say what even yeah
no it had right and jigsaw and all that
stuff we're like
woohoo okay so we're GNA do a little
report out
now and I just want to get a sense from
each group because we've done these
little I'm going to make you move in a
minute and there's a purpose for this
because this is actually um I'm like
that awkward person at the cocktail
party right like go go up and I'll talk
to one person but the whole purpose is
to get everybody talking so I'm going to
have a couple people from each each
group that aren't particularly um like
that are okay to just move around to
move to the next group so that the next
conversation you have can be with a
couple different people and you can
introduce yourselves again but just some
of the takeaways um kind kind of talk a
little bit about in from this group were
there differences in Target audiences
that you found what what were your
content
areas that really really we have music
we have math awesome well those two are
really connected right they are but
their grading is very different yes also
true exactly and how to accomplish that
um I'm from spian so we're sort of
crossing a range of disciplines and
we're sort of in development with our
first Suite of courses right now so um
you're much of a partner as an
institution um and then CH you can oh
yeah and you know I'm from a nonprofit
we're a new member of edex and so um
we're focused on um you know bringing
our uh research and content and putting
it on
a I think you I think it was on was it
on guys yeah you're good all right not
connected it's not huge yeah I think
just into the camera camera yeah and and
so as we think about audience for the
work that we're doing in my company
called Catalyst um we don't have the
traditional student Learners we have
corporate Learners okay so it's a very
different approach um for maybe some of
the traditional thinking about around
what and how a moo is created
so and then um I'm at adex I'm one of
the program managers and we're working
on an initiative right now where we're
expanding our course offerings to
include more introductory in like high
school and pre-ol courses so um that's
that's kind of what our target audience
that's awesome that's where we are we
should connect afterwards okay so I'm
just going to come around here kind of
give everybody a chance to talk about
their target audience um it was
definitely interesting this morning
because I I want to take like 15 mukes
now right I can't because I'm in
graduate school myself but it's like
that continual informal learning which
is what we're so trying to f
at kind of the community college level
that that confidence and that continual
lifelong
learning so we're trying to build um an
edx that will change the nature of
computer science in 11th grade so that
opens access to every single person 11th
grade not just the people who have
traditionally gotten computer science
only one in 12 high school students has
a computer science course at their High
School one in 12 so if you happen to
roll the roll the die with your parents
and live in the right City in the right
suburb uh then you'll get access but but
otherwise you're not getting access so
we're trying to create a course that
will be Blended that will be you know
coming from above but Spock delivered so
that each High School teacher can grab
it and feel like it's a resource and
work within even if it's a technology
person who doesn't really know the
material the mo kind of drives it and
they're in there to help it so it's kind
of a blended model for that to to change
that conversation broaden participation
in
Computing and I'm not developing a moo
but my interest in muks has always been
in the sort of broadening participation
Open Access and how to make that really
a reality because it's currently not um
at least at the exmo level and so I
think for me it's really you know I'm
very interested in oers and how to make
o ARS useful for as many people as
possible and sort of what
characteristics and features should they
have to be to be um accessible and
useful for
all hi I'm Linda Grisham I'm at Mass
Massachusetts Bay Community College and
so uh I can ditto we can
ditto the the population of uh I guess
this is two years ago now uh we used
edex material uh for computer
programming course and uh brought it
down to our community college uh and we
had great success with it I mean we had
started out with um 18 students to
dropped out but all 16 finished and the
reason why is because the instructor
really looked at the material and said
okay this needs to be translated this
needs to be people don't realize how
much cultural bias is actually in the
materials that are there uh so he
provided contacts he provided vocabulary
and also he provided um interactive
tutorials in fact the students could
have done this fully online actually
with his tutorials and then with the
etics material that was there so um I'm
interested in what did she say the uh
equalized access oh yeah well that's
that's our mission anyways right so um
to speak to the Oar thing too so much of
what we found was either text based or
video and the interactiv piece is really
kind of missing and the activities piece
is really missing and so um I'm
encouraged that they're coming up with
some more of these interoperable
languages and so hopefully they won't
all be you know we've all had scorm
challenges
right I'm SEL and I'm from UT Austin
from um Austin Texas and we've I manage
the moo program um and we have project
managers who individually de help
develop the m
on campus and I'm I'm just really
interested in seeing all the variety of
projects and just the faculty
innovations that come out of these
because the moo platform really is a
place for also for faculty experiment
right they can go and
try to their heart's content sort of
like oh let me try an experiment with
online design on interactives and how
they might work out online so um it's
just amazing what faculty really come up
with as far as Innovations and trying to
make pedagogy and instruction ction sort
of translate on the online level so that
really motivates me just seeing the
variety that comes out in different
disciplines and different faculty
different departments all across
campus I'm Vana today or wait a minute
that's not vanway I don't know some
other person who
runs there we
go um Susan Huggins Kaplan University
I'm the director of a new initiative
that we just launched uh not even 60
days ago open college at Kap University
started actually last year as a small
project called open learning at Kaplan
University so we we put uh mukes out in
um the Kaplan environment which is a
little uh thinking outside the box to
attract people to the college to try out
some of our courses in the open space
without committ of tuition without
committ of enrollment to come try the
college if you liked us enroll and you
could also get credit for the mukes um
we had such um a great interest that we
thought we would solidify what were we
thought of as as open learning so we
transition to the open college at KU and
in the open College we've actually um
expanded our our focus and our goal of
helping Learners seek those open
resources to finish their degrees to
bring their open courses back to us and
we'll assess them for college level cred
and also award that degree uh we'll be
launching an open degree uh in about 60
days as well uh a lot of Assessments a
lot of Assessments um so we're really
really excited and who our audience is
um we're not really sure we're we think
it's going to be the motivated learner
we initially thought it was going to be
adult Learners with some college and no
degree and that's probably still our our
audience um but I think I think we'll be
surprised as we have with most of our
initiatives I think it's we're going to
have a varied
audience uh hi I'm shaing I'm from
Stanford University so I'm I work at an
uh initiative called understanding
language our PI Kenji hakuta he's like
the rockar in um educational policy so
what we do is we provide um Mooks for
teachers k212 teachers especially in
service teachers so the teachers who
took our courses should have access to
classroom why because we ask them to go
into the classroom record their students
conversation and then reflect we we
invited some kind of rubric for them to
look at the conversation and reflect on
it and I guess uh Ms for us um we not
only it's not just as a tool to deliver
the content to the participants teachers
but also we use it as a way to collect
um data as I said we ask teachers to
collect their student discourse samples
so we are actually thinking of re use
those student U language samples to make
a database that can feedback to the
whole education Society that's also the
oer thing we're thinking about um so
were our courses successful I guess so
because we have um a lot of school
districts and States get interested and
because this whole Mook is just free so
they all love to work with us and then
we start to like make more customized
content for example we're now working
with Seattle district and also La
District so um they took our courses and
then we also go into their students
classroom uh teachers classrooms to
record what they do in the classroom and
then we use all all those videos back
into our
courses um so I think um to define
success and as I also brought in our
group uh the platform we use is novoed
um which promotes like team
collaboration and we we believe that um
it's better for teachers to work with
maybe someone who who teach like them so
they can learn from each other but then
how do we um define success for this um
I guess there are different levels of
success for example since the
participants are teachers you want to
know first whether they they get the
concept from the course and then how do
they transfer that into their uh
instructional actions and then overall
their teachers like when we go to um
foundations ask for fundraising they
always ask how do you s how do you
assess the students like the students
performance is another thing that's a
big thing from how do we um define
success and um the other thing is since
we are doing team
collaboration maybe a lot of teacher
they come in they don't really imagine
they can have some kind of instructional
change but they just want to connect
with other people so maybe that's the
the other way to define success or
assess success so there are a lot of
challenges we're still trying to figure
yeah I think we're all there yeah not
just you
hello I'm Kim Kenyan associate director
of the center for teaching Excellence at
Cornell
University uh I could say so much but I
won't do that um we've actually been
through one round of mukes um we're
currently in our second round we don't
have our data back from our first round
yet like many people we're trying to put
that into a format that's usable for us
um we're a land grant institution we're
both private and public um so the
objective for creating the
really is varied depending on what the
faculty we're thinking about my role was
to support faculty with the Cornel X
team and developing the best courses
possible looking at backward design
outcomes activities assessment that
whole kind of idea um looking at the
data that we have seen so far and I use
data as a loose term um we have achieved
that particular goal but you know if
we're thinking about redefining
assessment um looking at at the edex
platform and some of the limitations of
utilizing the tools we would like to
continue to push kind of the boundaries
in that particular realm and I think um
you know measuring success at the
University level versus the faculty and
individual level is it's all over the
place um you know some folks might say
well we want to reach high school
students but many of us know that high
school students in most cases aren't
actually who's actually taking these so
that's that you know how do you measure
I don't know uh to be quite honest with
you given that we have different ideas
about what the target audience is um and
we don't have our data back so we're
learning um we you know we're in the
midst of the pilot kind of stage one
maybe two and we will continue to
re-evaluate follow kind of the norm of
assessment planning um and and continue
to improve
hopefully thank you thank you so much I
really appreciate all of you sharing did
we have another request to share or are
you just coming back this way I just
coming back this way oh okay great okay
so
um wow an hour goes really fast doesn't
it so um I was hoping okay so this is I
I was going to do this like a kind of
shock and awe thing but um looking at
the design and delivery um in terms of
the intentional process and I know the
group that I was sitting with we did
have kind of a a discussion that there
was backwards design and there was kind
of this intentional process going into
it because this has been hurry up and
Muk in a lot of instances that kind of
process for intentional design and
delivery hasn't always happened so I was
going to have you discuss that and then
I was going to say now create a tweet
but because we don't probably have time
to um discuss in detail and then create
tweets um just work in the groups that
you're already in and create 140
characters actually try to do it in 130
because then we can put um you know at
the learning with muk's thing and
everybody can see them so one for each
of you individually about your specific
design and development process um and I
let's keep this really brief because I
want to give just a few minutes at the
end for what could you um B borrow or
steal from someone else's Muk either the
Muk that I shared with you or a
different moo in order to inform your
practice moving mov forward so we'll
take just a couple of minutes do this
actually individually otherwise it'll
take too long and then we'll talk a
little bit about what elements you might
like to take or experiment with or
something that maybe even someone else
in your group said that you like to
incorporate moving forward um so two or
three minutes if even if you're not on
Twitter it doesn't matter I'm going to
Tweet them so just take a couple minutes
less than 140 characters 130 if you can
do
it how were they designed and
developed
okay people are going to think I'm not
paying attention to my own presentation
because I'm
tweeting
for
okay one more
minute if you haven't tweeted before
I'll I'll come to you
last
all right anybody have
one 130 characters is harder than you
might think okay we'll take another
minute no
pressure
all right go for it I converted my
textbook into interactive visualizations
and problems added taet videos and then
got
shingled is that true okay is that 130
characters or less I'm sure it is okay
all right not 130
words okay start at the beginning I'll
see how much we can get it converted my
textbook into interactive visualizations
and problems made tablet
videos and then go
shingles
okay say it one more time I'm sorry
converted textbook converted my textbook
into interactive visualization and
problems made tablet
videos uhhuh and got shingles and got
shingles
okay got it all right next one uh focus
on rich media learning with an emphasis
on creating a supportive Community with
shared interests and diverse
backgrounds I got rich media learning
with an emphasis okay on creating a
supportive
Community with shared interest and
diverse
background
and if you are on Twitter you can go
back and um retweet these and identify
yourselves if you want to
obviously all right
next I don't
listen say say what you tweeted yours I
don't oh you already tweeted it I don't
listen well so I already tweeted mine oh
no no no that's okay if you already
tweeted it that's all right does anyone
else want to
share if you don't want to serious
seriously I'm not going to pressure you
and I said modular modularize modularize
that's actually a really interesting
thing cuz I think we are going to see
more of that in the future all right
well I just wanted to wrap up here we're
at time thank you all so much for being
willing to talk so much I think that's
what's been um so powerful about a
workshop like this is you can really dig
in and get to know other people if you
would like uh a business card I have um
we believe in open so if you want any
resources from me um also we just
recently um
published an article I forget what
Journal um called The Many Shades of
mukes about six different mukes at six
six different colleges that were the
first qm recognized mukes in the nation
so if you uh are looking up that it's a
very interesting um article about that
so thank you all so much and go forth
wait a minute I have a slide that says
go forth and moo we had more activities
we didn't get through go forth and Muk
well thank you so
much